Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
C’est sans doute quand
on risque de la perdre, l’existence,
qu’on se rend compte
qu’elle est précieuse et fragile.
1985, je suis jeune, gentil,
je suis maigre - ça va !
(Rires)
Je m’en vais...
Je suis guide de montagne
et un ami me dit :
«Tu devrais aller en Colombie.
Au nord de ce pays, il y a
une montagne extraordinaire
qui s’appelle la Sierra Nevada
de Sainte-Marthe.
Ses sommets enneigés sont à moins
de 42 kilomètres de la mer des Caraïbes.»
Je ne résiste pas, je monte,
je vais là-haut.
À 5000 mètres, un œdème pulmonaire,
de l’eau dans les poumons,
plus d’oxygène dans le sang.
Il n’y a pas de douleur physique.
Mais simplement, vous êtes un petit tas,
quelque part dans la montagne,
et vous avez juste 10% d’oxygène
dans la tête pour vous dire :
«Ça va être compliqué.»
Et j’ai eu la chance que des gens que nos
sociétés modernes ont appelé des sauvages,
des archaïques, des primitifs,
des autochtones,
qui vivaient repliés dans cette montagne
pour fuir la barbarie de notre modernité
aient la gentillesse de passer par là
et malgré les maltraitances
qu’on leur a fait subir,
m’aient récupéré par terre et mis sur
des mules pour me descendre en altitude,
pour me soigner et pour me sauver la vie.
Ces Indiens, ces autochtones, ces Kogis,
seraient les derniers héritiers
des grandes sociétés précolombiennes
du continent sud-américain.
4000 ans d'histoire ininterrompue.
Je suis dans leur hutte, je récupère
et à un moment dans la journée,
je sors de la hutte
pour aller regarder dans
quel village je suis arrivé.
Et devant la hutte,
des petites tomates cerises,
celles qu’on mange parfois à l’apéritif,
qui poussent par terre,
les tomates rampantes.
Et comme les tomates touchent
le sol, elles pourrissent.
J’ai fait des grandes écoles en France.
Et pendant ces grandes écoles,
on vous explique
que vous allez faire
partie de l’élite de la France.
Donc, l’élite de la France regarde
ces tomates et se dit :
«C’est ballot, ces Indiens ne savent pas
cultiver les tomates.
Je vais leur apprendre.»
Me voilà parti dans la forêt tropicale
couper des tuteurs
et redresser la trentaine
de plants de tomates devant la hutte.
Magnifique jardin à la française.
Les Kogis reviennent de leurs champs.
C’est essentiellement des agriculteurs.
Et puis se mettent autour de moi
et regardent comme ça.
Et il y en a un qui me dit :
«Qu’est-ce que tu fais ? »
Je lui dis, en essayant de trouver
mes mots, pour ne pas les vexer,
que je leur apprends à sauver
leurs récoltes de tomates.
Un deuxième me regarde et me dit :
«Tu sais, si on a mis ces tomates
comme ça, à l’entrée de la hutte,
c’est parce qu’elles dégagent
un tanin très fort
qui évite que les insectes
ne rentrent dans la hutte.
En fait, c'est un insecticide naturel.
Donc, si ça ne t’embête pas
de tout remettre en état,
ça nous arrangerait.»
(Rires)
Voilà.
(Applaudissements)
Je n’ai pas appris ça
dans les grandes écoles.
On peut appeler ça de l’humilité,
de l’écoute aussi, pas mal...
Et puis, j’ai découvert aussi
la solidarité de la vulnérabilité.
Quand on est à deux doigts de mourir,
le fil de l’existence entre les doigts,
on est bien content
qu’un rouge, un vert, un jaune,
un petit ou un grand, vous tende la main.
Et je me rappelle que je suis dans
leur hutte et je leur demande :
«Que puis-je faire pour vous remercier ?
Vous m’avez sauvé la vie. »
Ils me parlent de leur montagne,
une pyramide montagneuse,
[à l’écran], 80 kilomètres de côté,
cernée par la guérilla,
les paramilitaires, les pilleurs
de tombes, le tourisme, les mines,
les exploitants de bois précieux,
enfin bref...
Ils ont perdu, ou plus exactement,
on leur a pris 80% de leurs terres
dans les 80 dernières années.
Donc, ils me répondent :
«Ben, si tu veux vraiment nous remercier,
aide-nous à récupérer
nos terres ancestrales,
celles qu’on nous a piquées
depuis Christophe Colomb.»
Et moi je m’entends dire : «Ben oui,
évidemment, quel est le problème ?»
Donc, ça a été un peu long
car les civilisés comme on s’appelle,
sont bons pour la parole mais ont parfois
du mal à passer dans les actes, comme moi.
Donc dix ans plus tard, j’ai créé une
association, Tchendukua - Ici et Ailleurs,
qui s’est fixé comme objectif
de rendre les terres à ces Indiens.
On ne va pas s'embêter.
Donc, qui collecte des fonds,
pour racheter des terres et les rendre.
Voilà, c’est à la fois magnifique.
On a réussi à racheter
3000 hectares de terres
sur lesquelles il y a 1800 hectares
régénérés en termes forestiers,
des oiseaux qui reviennent,
des sources qui recoulent,
et des gens qui sont heureux,
qui peuvent choisir leur parcours de vie.
Puis, quand on regarde
une carte, c’est ridicule.
Mais peut-être que ça a généré une chose
encore plus importante : la confiance.
C’est-à-dire que des civilisés
et des archaïques,
après une histoire tumultueuse,
ont commencé à se faire confiance.
Je leur explique que ce n’est pas
simple de trouver de l’argent.
Et ils me disent : « Si tu veux,
on vient t’aider en France.
- Ah ouais, d’accord, ok. »
On organise un voyage en France.
Ils arrivent à Roissy et arrivés à Roissy,
ils me demandent :
« Pourrait-on voir des sages ? »
Oh !
Question délicate.
Il y a forcément des sages
chez nous, mais où sont-ils ?
S’il y a des sages, ils sont bien cachés,
je ne les ai pas rencontrés.
Bref, on sort de l’aéroport,
on se retrouve sur le périphérique.
Ce n’est pas une photo
idéale, mais imaginez
sortir de votre forêt tropicale,
arriver sur le périphérique.
C’était 18 heures, des voitures
et des camions partout.
Des petits panneaux qui clignotent :
« Ralentissez ! » ;
vous vous gazez, en clair.
Il faut rouler à 70 km/h
car il y a des particules fines.
Et ils me demandent ce qui
est marqué sur le panneau.
« Laisse tomber, c’est un peu
compliqué à expliquer. »
Bref, nous continuons notre périple
et nous allons voir des sages
vers Chambéry :
le TGV jusqu’à Lyon et une voiture
pour ceux qui font encore du ski
sur les quelques plaques
de neige qui restent,
il y a une autoroute avec deux tunnels.
Ils sont dans la voiture derrière moi.
Du coup, zzzzoup,
on arrive devant le premier tunnel
et là je sens le «heu »,
à l’idée de rentrer dans ce trou noir
et nous rentrons dans le tunnel.
on le traverse et à la sortie du tunnel,
un de nos invités Kogis me dit :
«Pourquoi vous faites des trous
dans la terre comme ça ?
- C’est pour aller plus vite, gagner
du temps, ça évite de faire le tour. »
Long temps de silence
et la petite voix me dit :
«Mais vous voulez
aller jusqu’où plus vite ?»
Oh la question !
Question du sens à laquelle on n'a pas
énormément de réponses aujourd'hui.
Et nous continuons notre voyage
et nous arrivons dans le comité
de direction d’une entreprise
dont le dirigeant a eu la gentillesse
de prendre en charge
une partie des billets d’avion pour
que les voyageurs arrivent jusqu’à nous.
Belle rencontre, beaux échanges.
Nous sortons de ce CODIR,
comme on dit dans le jargon.
Et là, un Kogi me tire
par la manche et me dit :
«Comment font-ils pour décider ?
- Comment ça décider ?
C’est quoi la question ?
-Eh ben oui, il y avait onze garçons
qui nous accueillaient et pas de filles.
Donc, ils ont qu’une moitié
de l’intelligence.
Comment prendre des bonnes décisions
avec une moitié de l’intelligence ?»
(Applaudissements)
Bon, en fait, ce que nous demandent
les Kogis, c’est un peu de respect,
un peu de qualité d’être ensemble,
un peu d’écoute.
Si on résume : arrêter de faire
la guerre avec la nature.
Réconciliation masculin-féminin.
On est différents et c’est chouette
de se rencontrer quand on se respecte.
Et puis donner du sens globalement
et respecter nos valeurs.
Respecter les valeurs, c’est apprendre
à se mettre en lien, en qualité d’être,
en qualité de présence.
On dit souvent que l’autre me renseigne
sur ce que je ne sais pas de moi.
Vous voulez tenter l’expérience ?
On peut mettre un peu
de lumière dans la salle ?
Oh merci !
On est nombreux donc, soyez
bien attentifs aux consignes.
On n’a pas beaucoup de temps,
je vais me faire gronder.
Je vais vous proposer de vous lever.
Si vous voulez bien vous lever,
ça vous faire bouger.
Oh, ce n’est pas une messe, hein !
Une fois debout,
deuxième partie de l’exercice,
vous vous tournez vers quelqu’un
que vous ne connaissez pas,
frère, ami, conjoint, rien, un inconnu,
quelqu’un où vous dites : «Oh là là !»
Voilà.
Alors choisissez quelqu’un
que vous ne connaissez pas.
Donc, normalement, on a des binômes
avec des gens qui ne se connaissent pas.
Ça va ?
Et s’il vous plait, silence,
autrement, on ne va pas y arriver.
Suite de l’exercice, si vous êtes
d’accord de continuer, oui ?
Ok, fermez les yeux et on ne s’endort pas.
Fermez les yeux,
mais gardez les oreilles ouvertes
pour entendre ce que je vais vous dire.
Vous êtes en binôme.
Des gens qui ne se connaissent pas.
Si vous êtes seul, levez la main
et cherchez un autre.
Aucune raison de rester seul
à se regarder dans le blanc des yeux.
Lorsque je vous le dirai, pas avant,
lorsque je vous le dirai,
vous ouvrez les yeux
et vous vous regarderez,
pas tout à fait dans les yeux parce
qu’on louche, mais autour des yeux,
avec le plus de bienveillance possible
pour cet inconnu qui est en face de vous.
Attention, c'est parti.
Ouvrez les yeux, une minute en silence,
en regardant cet inconnu
en face de vous avec bienveillance.
Je vous en prie, en silence.
Bien sûr, on a envie de rire,
il y a de l’émotion.
Essayez d’être en présence
de cette relation improbable,
ce jour TEDx de La Baule sur l’existence.
Exister.
Exister à l'autre.
Exister à soi.
C’est long, hein !
(Rires)
Une minute, vous pouvez vous
remercier pour le voyage.
(Rit)
(Applaudissements)
C’est quand même génial, ce truc !
Vous avez passé une minute à ne rien dire
et vous vous applaudissez.
Vous êtes remarquables.
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
En fait, ces Indiens Kogis
et les peuples autochtones en général,
nous confrontent à deux choix possibles.
Pas trois, pas quatre, deux.
Le premier choix :
nous continuons la colonisation
de notre planète,
les matières premières, l’exploration
et malheureusement la destruction.
On sait que l’été 2023 va être
le plus chaud qu’on ait jamais vécu
puisque le courant El Niño qui balaye
les côtes de l’Atlantique va arriver.
Nous avions la Niña qui refroidissait
les côtes, c’était déjà chaud.
Alors si on a le Niño qui réchauffe,
ça va être compliqué, bref...
on ne va pas en faire la liste, on sait
qu’il s’annonce des futurs incertains.
Les Kogis nous proposent une autre voie :
si on pouvait dialoguer ensemble,
si on pouvait se réconcilier avec la vie.
C’est une phrase de Michel Serres,
le philosophe :
«Nous sommes le monde,
nous fonctionnons comme le monde,
mais nous l’avons oublié.
Il faut nous réconcilier avec la vie
en nous et la vie autour de nous.»
Très modestement, à ma mesure,
j’ai essayé la deuxième option
de l’incarner, de marcher nos mots.
Ça se traduit par quoi ?
Par une école primaire
qu’on a créée dans la Drôme,
il y a dix ans maintenant,
où on essaie de préparer
les enfants à ce monde,
à faire ensemble la coopération,
retrouver la conscience de la nature.
Et la baseline de cette école primaire,
c’est comment donner envie aux
enfants de ne pas aller en vacances.
Très embêtant pour les parents
parce que les enfants leur demandent :
«Quand est-ce qu’on rentre à l’école ?»
Pas habituel ça, comme concept.
Voilà, ça marche plutôt bien,
même si c’est difficile dans notre pays
d’innover en matière éducative.
Le deuxième registre qu’on essaie
d’explorer pour remettre du vivant
dans nos pensées, récits et histoires,
c’est de faire dialoguer les peuples
racines, autochtones, traditionnels
avec la science.
On a invité quatre chamans Kogis à venir
dans la Drôme, 25 scientifiques,
et on leur a posé la même question :
faites-nous un diagnostic de santé
territoriale d’un petit coin de la Drôme.
Les Kogis auraient-ils
des choses à nous dire
sur nos territoires
qu’on ne connaisse pas ?
Magnifique !
Je ne vous en ferai pas la description
générique tellement ce serait long.
Il y a un livre magnifique, «Le Chemin
des pierres», paru chez Actes Sud -
Vous avez noté, c’est bon -
qui raconte cette histoire.
L’idée, c’est en fait d’écrire
un nouveau récit, une nouvelle histoire
qui donne de la perspective
aux jeunes générations.
Puis un troisième petit projet appelé
EK-KO, je vous le chuchote : EK-KO,
c’est : comment remettre
du féminin dans le corps social ?
Parce que vous avez peut-être des enfants.
On sait que pour faire un enfant,
il faut une énergie masculine et féminine.
Or dans notre corps social,
l’énergie féminine fait peur,
est source d’émergence
et pourrait permettre le dialogue,
donc on l’a éradiquée.
Donc remettre du féminin,
c’est remettre de l’émergence.
Je vous laisse aller regarder,
c’est remettre du vivant, en fait.
Je terminerai par deux petites histoires.
La première histoire, c’est lorsque
les Kogis sont venus en France,
nous avons été invités au Quai d’Orsay.
Le Quai d’Orsay,
c’est les ors de la République.
Vous voyez le bâtiment
au bord de la Seine ?
J’étais en petite Visa ce jour-là.
Curieux, les huissiers nous ont ouvert
la porte, avec une petite Visa.
Nous montons les escaliers,
nous sommes reçus dans le hall d’honneur
et nous arrivons dans une salle
de réception.
Les trois personnes membres du cabinet
du ministre de l’époque nous reçoivent
et demandent aux Kogis de se présenter.
Les Kogis se présentent,
présentent leur situation.
Et la réponse des gens qui
nous accueillent est la suivante :
«En fait, vous vivez un génocide.»
Ces Indiens vivent un génocide.
Je demande à nos hôtes :
«Qu’est-ce qu’on fait ?»
Comment répond-on à ça ?
La réponse est : « Remplissez le Cerfa
trois, trois, six, neuf, dix.
S’il est bien rempli et déposé
au bon bureau, d’ici quelques mois,
vous aurez quelques milliers
d’euros de subventions. »
Nous sortons de la salle de réunion,
nous retrouvons dans le hall d’honneur.
Et Merci madame, c’est formidable,
merci Monsieur, c’est génial, on se salue.
Et là, essayez d’imaginer le truc.
Un Kogi pieds nus dans son habit de Kogi,
s’en va dans un petit coin
de la salle d’honneur.
Canapé magnifique, polochons
superbes avec des pompons dorés.
Il prend un polochon
et il s’en va vers la sortie.
C'est très étrange comme moment.
Je disais au revoir à une dame,
et je vois les yeux de la dame
qui suivent le polochon, l’air de dire :
« Qu’est-ce qu’il fait le con ? » (Rit)
Mais on ne pouvait pas l’arrêter,
c’est un invité.
Un garde républicain avait les yeux
qui roulaient dans ses orbites
car on ne lui avait pas dit de l’arrêter
ou de lui dire au revoir avec le polochon.
Il s'en va vers la sortie.
Comment vous résumer ce moment ? (Rit)
Quand il arrive sur la porte,
je vois tout son corps qui rigole.
En fait, il se marre comme une dinde.
Et la leçon que j'en tire, c'est qu'on
vit tous des moments compliqués.
L’avenir est peut-être sombre,
mais garder la force de cette poésie,
garder la connexion à l’innocence
et à la joie de l’enfance,
c’est une chose qui
transcende les montagnes.
On leur dit qu’ils vivent
un génocide et ils font : (Siffle)
C’est la classe, quoi.
C’est la classe, non ?
Bon, et la deuxième petite histoire.
Un moment, je leur ai demandé :
« Quel est le mot
que vous utilisez pour dire
produire du savoir,
produire de la connaissance ? »
Puisque dans ce dialogue, on veut produire
un nouveau rapport au monde,
une nouvelle compréhension de la nature.
Ils m’ont donné un mot : Shibulama.
Pour comprendre une culture,
il est intéressant de rentrer
dans la traduction fine du mot utilisé.
Le mot, la langue, c’est le reflet
d’une manière d’être au monde.
Donc j’ai demandé aux Kogis
qu’ils me traduisent les quatre syllabes :
shi, bu, la, ma.
Shi, ça voudrait dire
la connaissance unitaire.
Par exemple la géologie
pour un territoire,
ou bien la climatologie,
ou bien l’hydrologie.
Pour un corps, ça peut être un organe,
le foie, le cœur, les reins.
C’est une unité, un shi, dans leur langue.
Shibu : peut-on les faire dialoguer ?
C'est mieux que les organes
dialoguent ensemble.
Ça vous évite de tomber malade.
Sur un territoire, peut-on faire dialoguer
l’hydrologie, la climatologie,
la géologie, la faune, la flore
pour avoir une vision plus large de
ce qui se passe dans un territoire,
qui du coup ne devient plus un paysage,
mais un pays sage,
ne devient plus un objet, mais un sujet,
quelque chose qui est vivant.
Et si on va jusqu’au bout, Shibula.
Quand on fait dialoguer les disciplines,
les organes et les regards,
le dialogue, les gens,
on arrive à quelque chose plus près,
je n’ose pas dire de la vérité,
mais de la réalité,
car on a croisé les regards,
on comprend mieux les situations.
Mais il faut du dialogue.
Shibula-ma, ma, ça désigne le
Qi Gong, le tai-chi-chuan,
le Qi, l’énergie vitale.
Si on arrive à reprendre une vision
globale sur un corps humain,
un territoire, une société,
alors on peut faire recirculer
l’énergie de la vie et de la joie.
Finalement, ce que nous disent
ces sociétés
qui n’ont jamais coupé leurs liens
d’alliance avec la nature :
retrouvons ensemble
le chemin de l’enthousiasme.
Et l’enthousiasme veut dire :
traversé par la vie.
Merci beaucoup !
(Applaudissements)